fa un freddo boia fatti sono con
l'affaire pina che mi ha lasciato mia
mamma appella a tutti i ragazzi e bes
perché dove c'è un po siamo arrivati
alla fine dell'anno anche quest'anno a
fine anno faccio un best of di che cosa
è successo durante l'anno ma lo faccio
non mettendo scene a caso commentando le
scene migliori dell'anno ho date
un'occhiata a tutti i video che ho fatto
nel 2017 ho scelto quale secondo me
quali secondo me erano i video migliori
dell'anno e oggi volevo proporveli per
vedere com'è andato un pochettino nostro
anno e vediamo
cioè all'inizio di quest'anno sono
andato a sciare per la prima volta nella
mia vita tra l'altro con email
de carli insomma eravamo in montagna
laurea registrato questa scena dio che
cade rovinosamente era una montagna
basta
denuncio ragazzi non ho mai scelto prima
è un casino quando non l'hai mai fatto
sono vivo un po per miracolo però sono
vivo abbiamo iniziato da dio quest'anno
mi dicono alla posizione numero 9 video
contro la tectonic è stato stupendo
ricordare come eravamo conciati noi nemi
coetanei parlo un tempo ai nostri tempi
quando andava di moda latex toni
possiamo vedere queste due entità
avvicinarsi l'una all'altra
una signora alla spalla letizia un
oledotto alcuno si gira si girano tutti
sguardi perplessi alla risposta del
tizio che scende le scale inizia a a
svitare il proprio braccio non c'e non
mi stupiscono loro che fanno questo mi
stupiscono gli altri che rimangono così
non avrei mai voluto fare questo video
perché in realtà volevo per reprimere
nel mio scrigno segreto tutto quello che
è stato il mio pad il nostro passato e
non ricordarlo mai più ho tirato fuori
dal vaso di pandora sta roba
non avrei mai voluto farlo ciari
buttiamo dentro e via posizione number e
it
il bug di youtube ho messo il bug di
youtube la posizione numero 8 perché
anche youtube ha avuto un anno
incredibile per chi non lo sapesse c'era
questa possibilità di togliere iscritti
alla gente non sto scherzando la
succedeva quando tutti i visi scrive via
un canale il canale perdeva non uno ma
due iscritti non so come mai e quindi
tutti iscrivervi una volta così vi
faceva guadagnare un iscritto divisi
scrive viene facevi perdere due così la
gente perdeva iscritti di continuo l'ho
preso 1962
basta basta basta cancellando tutti i
siti falci possiamo perdere i siti a
terni
ciao stefanino ma bruxelles reazione
choc a video ambiguo semplimente questa
ragazza che faceva fa un classico video
dove tagliali squish non l'ha ancora
capito cosa sono discussi solo che uno
switch aveva una forma un po ma un pene
adesso vediamo cosa c'è dentro a questo
da dove comincio natalizio più parti zio
votiamolo beh io nun c'ha le sue
passioni di videogiochi grazie a dio ci
ha ancora ben mabrouk sex falco merino è
ammetto
merita almeno almeno e di esser in
classifica dire no beh non so parlare
l'inglese smetterla di fare il finto
english avete presente la bombola passi
sono già avete presente meglio era
questa specie di di trend che andava su
youtube dove guardavi delle foto di tib
o dtp e dicevi se te lo bombe resti sete
la bomber è stasera passeresti ok faceva
ridere e prendere per il culo chi lo
faceva insomma una delle persone che
aveva fatto questa sfida non era gianpi
tech ma era la ragazza di gianpi te e
tra le persone che avrebbe dovuto
scegliere se bombare o meno indovinate
chi c'era allora paciello a bonn
biomasse ma noi arriviamo al punto
focale di questo video davvero monaci
consiglio la piccola so quanti anni ha
ultimo 20
gianpi tech e degli occhiali nuovi a la
tua ragazze gli occhiali grazie perché
si incazzano già vite crociata c'era
bisogno di fare accensione del mio von
permalosi qua su youtube
mamma mia c'è lo spirito natalizio siamo
felici ci avviciniamo al podio con il
quarto posto spada laser con mio padre
ho fatto un video su star wars con mio
padre e dove ho sfidato appunto mio
padre a un combattimento con le spade
laser
volete
siamo arrivati al podio dei tre video
che reputo i migliori del 2017 è un
podio molto personale ce ne sono tanti
di video quindi molto probabilmente voi
apprezzate anche altri video da mettere
nel podio però secondo me questi non
sfigurano per niente alla posizione
numero 3 troviamo la vj versus insetto
gigante quest'anno dovuto affrontare ben
diverse creature provenienti dalla bocca
dell'inferno una di queste si chiama
scudi gera che in teoria è un nemico dei
ragni si dice che il nemico del tuo
nemico è tuo amico però se fai schifo al
cazzo se comunque mio nemico o mio dio
no no no ragazzino dai ma porca eva
lercia noi non posso vivere così dai
ragazzi vi giuro ammazzo guardavo il
peccato che faceva faceva schifo
quindi facciamo le valigie e giulia sul
palco ha fatto troppe news un sacco na
fate veramente un sacco per niente c'era
questo festival chiamato in summer
festival non vorrei dire una cagata
parisi si teneva in piazza del popolo a
roma in diretta su canale 5 tra l'altro
dove gabry ponte ha suonato davanti a
tutti quanti e ha chiamato me giulia in
consolle perché facciamo parte del video
punto di gabry ponte durante la la
performance sul palco ci siamo
avvicinati io e giulia e al momento del
bacio è partito un e volevi che secondo
me è stato uno dei miei migliori troll
riusciti sono fosse per il primo posto
di questa classifica perché al primo
posto della classifica dei migliori
video del 2017 di fa vj troviamo
fa malissimo battere sulla schiena con
ciò budget per il tamburo non rompete
nambla
frank della tavola luigia non so se
conoscete da tavola riceverla spiega in
breve c'è questa tavola c'è questo coso
michela vi ammazzo litri turo i parenti
c'è questo col
da lei visto che 4 padano come le loro
madri vi lascio la spiegazione che avevo
fatto direttamente nel video nel video
sesso quindi la tavola ouija che questa
qua la lente della tavola ouija che va
posizionata sopra la tavola ci si mette
su un tavolo con le luci spente in
silenzio con gli amici e tutti quanti
temono mettere il dito sulla lente nella
tavola se lo spirito è presente la lente
si muoverà sulle lettere cercando di
formare le parole o delle sentenze ho
deciso di farci un prank ho attaccato
sul retro della lente della tavola
questo tappo che contiene una calamita
il tappo dello stesso colore della lente
quindi si confonde benissimo col pezzo
dopo di che i ragazzi o delle altre
calamite attaccate ad un calzino che
metterò sotto il ginocchio in modo tale
da poter controllare la lente sulla
tavola in questo modo vabbè avete capito
quindi io seduto comodamente davanti a
un tavolo con la tavola ouija davanti mi
basterà mettere in ginocchio sotto il
tavolo per poter muovere la lente che
sta sulla tavola ouija e far credere a
tutti quelli che sono intorno che la
rete si stia muovendo da solo è
ovviamente marco secondo voi ci sarà mai
cascato di brutto il fatto è che non ha
avuto una reazione negativa nel senso
che una persona normale normalmente
sarebbe scappata cagando si addosso in
realtà la sua reazione è stata molto la
vera mente tentato di parlare col demone
chiedendogli delle cose della sua vita
cioè stato fantastico più grossi
le cose non c'è niente che è successo
magari non riesce a incanalarsi con opel
astra è un'azienda non fatemi in corea
non c'è nessuno li periodo diciamo il
punto ma può fare andando soprattutto
marco no no dai basta ragazzi o
scherzare ha già una cosa in due stavo
scherzando ma marco non far vincere con
almeno dell'associazione marco viola
veramente ripresa ma ci sono dei video
su internet di cose così rientriamo
chiediamo scusa ma tu sei così
tranquillo perché spiegherebbe così
tante cose
però comunque va sempre sullo quindi
facilmente ragazzi va bene così sta
tranquillo chiede a costo zero che ha
detto uccide saluta marco de turchini di
camera
questa è stata veramente una genialata
ragazza non è il video migliore
dell'anno senza rivali prof
quindi ragazzi questo è stato il nostro
2017 spero vi sia piaciuto il video
spero vi siano piaciuti anche video
commesso nella top
ovviamente ognuno ha i suoi gusti quindi
fatemi sapere qual è il vostro video
migliore secondo voi del 2017 che ho
fatto qua sotto nei commenti sono
curioso di andò alla vedere anche perché
forse farò una top ten dei video scelti
da voi appunto se li scrivete qui sotto
io vi ringrazio per aver guardato questo
video vi ringrazio per avermi fatto
passare un altro anno bellissimo perché
mi sono divertito un sacco
e spero di avervi divertito anche voi
non so parlare l'italiano però si fa
sempre in tempo di imparare ragazze che
vi sia per cento ragazzi con quello più
episodio concludiamo che questo 2017
buon anno a tutti vorrei farvi la
bandierina gli auguri ma non ho la
bandierina
però quel buon anno e buone feste a
tutti quanti ragazzi spero possiate
passare delle ottime vacanze e noi ci
teniamo come sempre ad un prossimo video
dunque questa è una penna che ho rubato
da ragazzi